c'est historique pour la première fois
une femme va arbitrer un match de
football lors d'un euro masculin
la pionnière c'est elle la française
stéphanie fera par une consécration pour
l'arbitrage féminin car il a fallu du
temps avant qu'ils ne se démocratise
vous pensez que si vous étiez marié vous
arbitres y est quand même oui pourquoi
pas oui oui pourquoi pas voilà les
questions composé à une arbitre en 1967
à l'époque très peu de femmes arbitrer
des matchs officiels
il faut attendre les années 70 pour les
voir plus souvent sur le terrain
mais là encore difficile pourra être
prise au sérieux
j'ai jamais vraiment gros problème enfin
une fois qu'un joueur qui était vraiment
très expliqué quand je lis ce que je
sais il avait commencé à l'été son chat
remarques sexistes commentaire déplacé
sur le terrain les femmes n'échappait
pas aux clichés
à partir des années 90 l'arbitrage
féminin connaît un tournant en 1994
laurence bio devenait la première femme
à arbitrer un match masculin au niveau
professionnel chez nous un arbitre je
dirais un arbitre je me dis que si une
femme a les capacités pour arbitrer ce
niveau-là n'y a pas de raison que parce
que justement c'est une femme elle et
pour sa chance
1996 nouvelle avancée nelly viennot est
la première femme a officié en tant qu
arbitre de touche lors d'un match de
première division masculine et je voyais
pas le parc de cette façon fret de la
télévision et c'est vrai que c'est
impressionnant
je pensais que les tribunes étaient plus
loin et ont fait elles sont proches du
terrain je suis très très contente
d'être ici
23 ans plus tard nouvelle étape de
franchie pour l'arbitrage féminin en
stéphanie fera par devenait la première
femme à diriger un match de ligue 1
[Musique]